voilà aujourd'hui pour vous parler de ce
smartphone là c'est le bamboo c'est le
paceman z le paceman zelda était
présente et déjà il ya quelques temps
si vous avez un peu de travers a été
présentée depuis quelques temps j'ai
attendu avant de vous pouvoir vous en
parlait justement par rapport aux
problématiques et eu entre eux huawei et
google huawei et les us qui du coup a
impacté la relation au web google pour
mettre les choses dans l'ordre
du coup aujourd'hui je peux vous en
parler sereinement tranquillement parce
que les choses avancent met en place se
résolvent donc bon déjà en tout cas vous
pouvez être sûr que d'un point de vue
purement licence ce smartphone ne
pouvait la voir vous aurez android ya
pas de souci tout va bien donc tout se
passe bien et tout va bien dans le
meilleur des mondes
à quelque chose près ce smartphone est
hyper intéressant et c'est une évolution
du ps marc est sorti en début d'année
dont je vous ai déjà parlé et le paceman
z est intéressant surtout pour un point
un point qu'il met en avant c'est le
fait d'avoir un grand écran sans
encoches et ça c'est bien avec cette
petite caméra escamotable c'est je
dirais le gros point fort de ce
smartphone c'est vraiment le gros focus
laden de ce smartphone est dis donc t'as
dit la katusha et dans celle là je vous
le montrer en détail à mais l'adn de ce
smartphone c'est effectivement le fait
de se dire je veux avoir du multimédia
je vais avoir un smartphone d'entrée
début milieu de gamme avec un grand
écran sans empoche donc ça c'est
vachement bien donc ça c'est vraiment
hyper cool avec suffisamment de
performance avec de l'eau jo qui va pas
trop mal
c'est vraiment pour moi laden de ce
produit donc si vous êtes à la recherche
de typologie de produits le paceman
rythme elle fait pour vous à côté de ça
il ya aussi des points qui sont un petit
peu moyen notamment niveau de la photo
de tout ça je vous le détailler
est il à notre plan qui est très très
bon mais je garde le meilleur pour la
fin
[Musique]
est-ce qu'il est pas mignon se paie
smart z grand écran alors il ya un peu
de bordures en haut en bas de tous les
côtés ce qui ne paraît pas déconnant vu
le positionnement tarifaire après c'est
un grand classique un bouton breen
compagnie o parra leur prise jack
ça c'est cool recharge usb c'est le
micro vous avez votre tiroir de cartes
sim qui situent juste là la petite
caméra escamotable elle le micro pour la
réduction de bruit capteur d'empreinte
digitale au dos qui marchait très bien
c'est un grand scandale ça marche bien
là vous avez deux effets lâche pas s'ils
voyaient bien on a deux effets
différents briand tous les deux qui sont
très sympas double module caméra bord
annonce un smartphone qui est bien qui
se tient bien en main qu'il y ait un
grand écran qui est un grand écran de
6,59 pouces de diagonale c'est l'ultra
foule view est plutôt bien vous avez dû
fhd plus de 1340 par 1080 pixels ces
duels cdc du tfc s'est pas ledit ps
c'est un peu moins bien que de n'dali ps
mais vu cet écran ça marche pas mal plus
en plus je vous montrais ya un petit
truc à modifier au niveau du calibrage
mais ça va ce que je vous conseille
c'est à dire dans vos paramètres vous
allez dans affichage et dans l'affichage
vous allez dans mois des températures de
couleur qui sont normales par défaut
mettez-vous en vivent
et là vous venez illégalement par défaut
il tire un petit peu sur un co espèce de
bleuté un peu violacé vous mettez en
chaude donc pour moi vivent chaude ça
casse un peu cet effet bleuté violacé
c'est à dire lutter un peu contre la
lumière bleue c'est un peu mieux c'est
pas mal et c'est beaucoup plus confort
pour le regard pour multimédia varier
ses coups le fait pas avare dans le
coche ça s'est vraiment bien on a un peu
la bordure à l'égard end ya des collants
et même pour une partie de ganic ça
c'est vraiment intéressant après le truc
un peu moins ou c'est le haut parleur
mono vous avez là il ya un peu sonné pas
énormément écouté on est sur un
smartphone williams ça se comprend
vraiment mais après si toutefois vous
galérez ya un truc qui est vachement
cool c'est que vous branchez votre
casque là et a tout de suite
l'expérience est bien meilleure le son
est bonne qualité vous avez suffisamment
de volume le spectre et mène donc c'est
vrai qu'ils voulaient profiter quelque
chose d'assez immersif au niveau de
l'audio vous faut un casque je vous
recommande alors une fois de plus à tour
sur n'était pas le volume trop fort son
dessin casque de bonne qualité si vous
voulez avoir une restitution de bonne
qualité mais moi pour l'avoir écouté
kaiser 75,06 de sony je trouve qu'il est
vraiment bien l'eau et ce1 hui 9.0 ça
marche bien c'est sympa ces pratiques
qui tombe sur un android 9 pas qu'on
nous dit là dessus pas de problème de
licence est d'ailleurs à ce sujet on
peut se marrer tu vois donald honte a
bien eus
les performances sont très
m avec un kirin 710 f il ne chauffe pas
particulièrement il n'a pas
particulièrement c'est un soc milieu de
gamme de chez elles silicone ça marche
bien c'est cool on n'a pas le top
performances de ce qu'on pourrait avoir
mais vu positionnement du smartphone on
va pas s'attendre non plus on trouve
c'est bien donc pour des parties du jeu
ça marchera bien
ne cherchez pas à faire tourner forte
avec là dessus mais plein de jeux dans
le plextor donc vous pouvez faire comme
ça c'est vachement bien
vous avez 4 gigas de ram qui vous offre
suffisamment de fluidité tout ça couplé
à 64 giga de stockage extensible grâce à
une carte microsd à s'asseoir 12 giga
donc en termes de stockage pour de la
musique pour des photos pour plein de
choses ça va vous avez suffisamment du
stockage pour mettre plein de jeux
dessus pour mettre des films des séries
pour du visionnage de netflix compagnie
c'est bien pour moi tout la gagne ce
smartphone c'est ce grand écran pour
écouter au casque des séries des films
vous êtes tranquille vous êtes bien
pouvoir jouer à des jeux c'est l'adn de
ce produit et en plus ça vous le faites
longtemps et le combat le gros point
positif c'est l'autonomie vous avez une
grosse batterie de 4000 millions paire
eur pour le recharger en usb type cc
bien c'est pratique c'est rapide ça
marche bien et vous gardez deux jours et
pour moi c'est tout l'intérêt parce que
dès lors qu'on va regarder des films des
séries
on sait tout de suite si vous passez à
un peu de temps dessus voir beaucoup de
temps dessus et bien commencé un petit
peu énergivores et comme là derrière
vous avez une grosse batterie faisait
quand même relativement tranquille donc
ça c'est bien alors après si vous
recevez beaucoup de batteries faisant
n'est pas avoir deux jours d'autonomie
vous aurez une journée d'autonomie deux
jours je dirais c'est sur un usage
standard sans trop déconner pour moi
c'est vraiment le combo écran audio
casque autonomie bien pour le visionnage
après on pourrait se dire tiens
peut-être que la partie photo va être
dingue mais la partie photo pour moi
elle est un peu en dessous vous avez un
double capteur vous avez capteur
principal de 16 mégapixels et ouvre à f
1.8 que vous avez un deuxième capteur à
l'arrière qui vient pour le mode
portrait capteur 2 mégapixels et
justement vous avez cette petite caméra
escamotable là ça c'est vraiment le truc
un peu positif un peu sympa et un peu
gadget c'est une caméra de 16 mégapixels
qui ouvre à f 2.2 kg annoncés pour
résister à plus de 100 milles fermetures
ouvertures
ça paraît quand même plutôt pas mal et
beaucoup mais c'est vrai que en règle
générale quand est-ce les autres
smartphones et sans renoncer à 300
milles donc je ne sais pas s'ils n'ont
pas passé le sens un millier le test ou
alors est-ce qu'il n'a pas contestée
jusque là bon sens ça restera quand même
c'est une énigmatique
après déjà 100 dès l'ouverture fermeture
bon moi je pense que vous tenez
je dirais deux ans sans aucun problème
minimum minimum sous quelques années la
selphy s'est passé quand on utilise le
plus pour vous montrer ça je récupère
mon macbook pro sur lequel j'ai mis mes
photos donc là les images que je
montrais prise à arles la voyez c'est
pas hyper mètres parce que vous avez
passé tel utilisateur donc dès que vous
chutez si ça bouge un petit peu ça se
voit et l'image va en pâtir
ça c'est pas hyper hyper précis il ya un
côté un peu floutée haussière il ya pas
non plus beaucoup de lumière là ça a
bougé voyez c'est hyper floués par
contre dès que j call et ça marche bien
je pour que les couleurs sont assez bien
entendu il n'y a pas beaucoup de lumière
mais ça fait le taff vu le
positionnement du smartphone là c'est
pareil pas beaucoup de lumière mais ça
bouge un peu tout de suite c'est fou que
ça rajoute du brut la moria l'ex-star de
suite ça marche beaucoup mieux ça va
beaucoup plus vite pour prendre les
photos donc on a moins ce problématique
de flou j'espère qu'ils sont assez ne
trouve que la colorimétrie est assez
juste là dessus c'est pas mal là
toujours à alain boyer est là pourtant
on en extérieur où je croise et d'une
rue je prends ma photo mais malgré tout
il ya un côté un petit peu flou donc dès
que ça bouge tout de suite c'est
problématique là ça bouge pas ça va bien
là ça ne bouge pas aussi s'est
parfaitement bien par contre voyez on
n'a pas trop de détails dans le ciel
avec le hdr laissera ce matin qui coûte
pas très cher non plus faut pas trop lui
en demander
là ça fonctionne l'âge propos c'est
assez imprécis ce qui est au niveau des
photos vous allez vers des éclairages
comme ça c'est pas génial
la vôtre les petites aberration s'est
pas complètement exceptionnel oui tout
de suite le traitement au niveau des
lumière des lampadaires s'est pas
complètement exceptionnel l'amf est
parti n'est pas très naturel vous avez
pris une petite aberration de tous les
côtés c'est pas ou fait la retenue c'est
pas du tout son sens complètement
apprécié sa malice et c'est pas terrible
le traitement il pas très très joli ce
côté là la gelée bien posé plaqué
savalli c'est le traitement pour moi il
pas ou feint j'étais vraiment le le
choix je dire assez négatif après on
n'est pas sûr impétrantes pro donc c'est
pas un smartphone qui fait complètement
optimisé que devant la puissance de
calcul derrière je me voyais voilà bah
c'est pas geiger s'est tenue toute assez
mauvaise c'est l'hôtel dans lequel
j'étais même la veille aurait pu faire
quand même vachement oui c'est pas ou
fille sim est ce que c'est un petit peu
dommage
le petit déj le matin-même lave tout ça
c'est un pressing haut niveau des
fraises vous le voyez là par contre il a
sorti pas trop mal le ciel ça va c'était
assez naturel ça c'est juste et la voyez
je me raccroche prend des fleurs et
c'est flou et ça vraiment je le regrette
au niveau de la caméra de celle fille ça
va pas trop mal on trouve un peu ce
qu'on a chez huawei gros standards donc
ça c'est plutôt pas mal et le mode
portrait et pas aux officines
ça vous fait bien flou ça reconnaît les
zones avec plus ou moins de perfection
mais la volée au niveau
du doigt avec l'éclairage derrière il
avait un petit peu de mal brassé si du
point de détail mais ce n'est pas
exceptionnel
on a donc un smartphone qui fait des
photos souvenirs lorsque vous avez plein
de lumière ça va si vous bougez un peu
tout de suite c'est beaucoup moins
précis est bon ce serait clairement le
paceman z c'est pas du tout la photo son
point fort ça permettra de choper
quelques souvenirs mais pas plus quoique
les quand même pas mal c'est que vous
avez quand même la petite sécurité que
vous avez sur toutes les petites caméras
pop up en tout cas du marché lorsque hop
le téléphone des textes qui tombe et
bien et vous même des messages comme
quand votre téléphone est tombé votre
téléphone pour est tombé pour éviter
d'endommager d'appareils photos sont
automatiquement rétracter continuent à
l'utiliser
oui ou non oui donc ça c'est plutôt pas
mal c'est aussi assez rassurant bon très
clairement l'appareil photo a été mis là
uniquement pour dégager l'écran mais il
n'y a pas un appareil photo de dingue
c'est pas un photophone on n'est pas sur
un truc ou fille sinon on est sur un
smartphone qui est suffisamment
performant avec une bonne autonomie avec
un grand écran pour le multimédia et
s'ils voulaient faire la photo tant
mieux ces bonus mais c'est pas trop son
adn donc moi je trouve plutôt pas mal
et alors attendez en termes de tarifs je
reprenne ma fiche
c'est un smartphone qu'on peut trouver
qui annonce à 279 euros 90 mais vous
pouvez trouver un peu moins cher
d'ailleurs si vous botte je me dis rien
dans la description peu trop autour des
230 euros
au final est-ce que ce pc mark z 2019
est intéressant et bien moi je dirais
que si vous avez un budget aux alentours
de 250 euros contre 230 250 270 euros et
que vous voulez pas faire des trucs de
ouf en photo là il est pas mal
il est pas mal de par l'écran de par la
taille de l'écran mais c'est vrai qu'à
prier gala la concurrence on trouvera
mieux au niveau de la fiche technique
mais si vous voulez un smartphone de
chez huawei si vous aimez
l'environnement huawei et 6 e p smart z
vous fait de l'oeil pour moi vous pouvez
y aller mais je vous dis vraiment pour
les usages que je vous donne dans cette
vidéo
et ne cherchez vraiment pas vous dire
c'est ouais c'est la photo c'est top non
vous allez être hyper déçu c'est pas du
tout ça
s'ils voulaient faire de la bonne photo
chez huawei et si vous voulez pas mettre
trop d'argent ali sur la génération de
l'année dernière à l'est sur un pv
allez voir que des lupins premier temps
vous pouvez en trouver un peu moins cher
et là ça sera beaucoup mieux et là pour
filtrer d'un bel écran mais par contre
le design sera pas du tout le même
à vous de nous dire ce que vous en
pensez est ce que
ce smartphone peut vous faire de l'oeil
est ce qui vous tente est ce que vous
aimez le côté comme caméra peut pas tout
moi je trouve ça cool on utilise un
smartphone avec une caméra pop up donc
j'aime beaucoup ça tout ça vraiment
intéressant d'avoir des grands écrans
dégager comme ça c'est cool
mark et moi tout ça on va en commentaire
et moi vous dis à demain vous fait des
gros bisous ciao